what is up everybody it's annamac here
for anime uproar and in this video
i will be breaking down everything we
know about the warhammer
titan the ninth and final titan shifter
power to be introduced
in the attack on titan story i will
explain this titan's unique powers
and abilities i will talk about its
history and
its holders and i will reveal the truth
about the mysterious tiber family the
ldn
noble family that has held the warhammer
titan in its possession
for many generations there is a lot to
talk about when it comes to this
incredible titan shifter so let's get
into it
if you enjoy our attack on titan videos
here on the channel and you want to see
more please leave a like to let me know
it really means a lot
and if you're new to animeopro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications huge thank you to all
of our anime uproar patrons who make
videos like this one possible i will
talk more about patreon at the end of
the video but for now please be advised
that this video does contain
attack on titan manga spoilers i will be
looking at all the available information
for the warhammer titan
including stuff that still hasn't been
revealed in the anime so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned the warhammer titan
is one of the nine different titan
shifter powers that emerged after the
death of the progenitor emir fritz
some 1700 years after the death of emir
the 145th king of eldia carl fritz
decided to abandon the constant wars and
conflicts on the continent
so he left the continent and took a
portion of the aldian population to the
island
of paradise on this island carl fritz
built the three walls and manipulated
the memories of the island's population
so that they would think that they were
the
only surviving humans in the world
essentially
king fritz wanted to completely isolate
himself from the affairs of the outside
world
so much so that he didn't even want his
subjects to know
that the outside world existed king carl
fritz decided to do this because he was
tired and ashamed of what the aldean
empire had become
the aldians were constantly at war with
other nations
and they were also constantly at war
with each other the various
ld noble families were always fighting
for control
of the different titan shifter powers
eventually
carl fritz was overcome with guilt over
what ldns had historically done to the
other nations and over what was
happening with the aldean empire
during his reign so he eventually
conspired with the tiber family
the long time possessors of the
warhammer titan
to bring his own empire to ruin and to
move his capital to the isolated island
of
parodies king fritz hoped that on this
isolated island he could create a
society that would be peaceful
and free of conflict essentially carl
fritz was hoping that everyone on the
island could live their lives in peace
at least for a time we all know how that
turned out since the island was never
really free
of internal conflict but isama seems to
be suggesting that this is simply
human nature whenever a large number of
people gather together to form a society
conflict crime and violence are
inevitable even if you are
on a completely isolated island after
carl fritz moved to the island
the tiber family remained on the
continent
and in fact they used the warhammer
titan power
to support the marlenes against their
fellow
aldians with the help of the tibers the
marlands were able to overthrow the
aldian empire and gain possession of
multiple titan shifter powers
including the colossal titan the armored
titan the beast titan
the female titan the jaw titan and the
kart titan
once the merlans emerged victorious in
this so-called
great titan war they began oppressing
and persecuting the aldean population
that remained
on the continent the only exception to
this was the tiber family itself
which maintained possession of the
warhammer titan and was granted the
status of
honorary marlan aristocrats so unlike
the rest of the aldian population on the
continent
the tibers were allowed to live in
lavish mansions outside of the
internment zones
and they were not required to submit to
oppressive measures such as being forced
to wear armbands that publicly
identified them as
aldians the tiber family is first
introduced in the story
after the time skip when zeke yeager
convinces the tibers to come out and
publicly support the next invasion of
parodies
island because the tibers are celebrated
in marley for having
sided with the marlians against their
fellow eldians
zeke was hoping that public support from
the tibers would soften marland public
opinion
about the other aldeans on the continent
especially now that these other aldians
were preparing to sacrifice
their lives in order to take down the
so-called
island devils basically many aliens on
the continent
desperately want the marlenes to see
them as good aliens
they want to be seen as different from
the so-called bad aldeans
on the island however we quickly learned
that there is more to the tiber family
than meets the eye officially the
marlayan people believe that they played
a major role
in winning the great titan war and
overthrowing the aldean empire
specifically a legendary marlene hero
called hellos
is believed to be the one who defeated
the earth devil and saved the world
from the aldian devils but according to
willie tiber the head of the tiber
family
that was all a lie and hellos
may never have even existed instead the
aldean empire was brought down by the
alliance of carl fritz and the tiber
family and the story of hellos was just
invented as a way to make the marlins
think that they are the ones who are
in control it is heavily implied that
the tiber family
is secretly playing a major role in
ruling the nation of marley
from behind the scenes so the marlenes
who hate
their elden minority so much are really
being controlled from behind the scenes
by
none other than a mysterious ld noble
family
the tibers the tiber family has been in
possession of the warhammer
titan for this entire time and they
never once used it to help the marlands
fight their many wars that took place
after the fall of the alien empire
instead the warhammer titan seems to
always be at the disposal of the tiber
family
and tiber family alone and it is always
ready to protect
them and them specifically that said i'm
honestly not sure
why the tiber family allows the ongoing
oppression
of their own eldean people if they
secretly call the shots
in marley why not use their influence
and clear talent for propaganda
to end the hate and discrimination
against the aldeans
i'm not sure if they just think that the
audience deserve to suffer because of
the sins that they committed against
other nations in the past which is
something that king fritz seems to have
believed
or if it just suits their own
self-interest to keep
things as they are after all if the
marlins are keeping all the other
aldians oppressed then the tibers don't
have to worry about a rival
ldn faction rising up and using the
titan shifter powers to take the tibers
down
either way the fact that the tibers can
just sit back
in their mansions and watch their own
people being mistreated on a daily basis
by the merlions is pretty freaking
grotesque
in my opinion on the day of the big
festival in liberio
aaron kills and eats willie tiber
as the head of the tiber family willie
was widely believed to be the current
holder
of the warhammer titan however it is
soon revealed that willie
was not a titan shifter at all instead
his sister
was the current holder of the warhammer
titan and after willy's death
his sister transforms and engages aaron
in battle the warhammer titan possesses
multiple distinct powers and abilities
the first is the ability to create
weapons using its special titan
hardening the warhammer titan can create
spikes that appear
all over the battlefield giant spears
and pikes that pierce through the enemy
a titan bow and arrow that allows it to
attack opponents from a distance
and of course it can create a giant
warhammer among
other weapons this titan's hardening
ability
is uniquely versatile and flexible and
that is what makes the warhammer titan
the perfect
offensive titan power the only drawback
is that overusing this unique hardening
ability can drain the user's stamina
very quickly on top of its special
hardening abilities
the warhammer titan has the power to
enclose its user
inside a protective crystal that looks
exactly like the crystal that annie was
able to seal herself
in this crystal protects the user from
being eaten by another titan so it is
very useful
and the user of the warhammer titan is
fully conscious
and able to control the titan from
inside this crystal
beyond that unlike with the other titan
shifters the warhammer titans user's
physical body
doesn't have to be located inside the
nape of the titan's neck
in fact the real body of the user
doesn't even have to be anywhere near
the titan's body as long as the titan
body
is connected to the human user through a
long string of flesh
the user can stay hidden away in a safe
location while still having full control
of the titan body this means that the
warhammer titans user can be safe inside
a crystal that is not even located in
the same vicinity as the titan's body
as long as that string of flesh is
connecting the titan and
its user if the string is cut then the
titan body will stop
moving but the user can then just create
a new titan
body in a place of their choosing with
yet another string that connects
the user to the new body this is
basically like having a titan game
controller
it's not wireless so it's more like a
gamecube controller than a ps5
controller
but still this special ability
drastically reduces the chances that a
warhammer titan user
will get eaten by a rival titan the
crystal within which the warhammer
titans user can conceal himself or
herself
is almost indestructible and so the only
known way to break through the crystal
is to use the jaw titan's incredibly
strong jaw
to bite through it during the battle of
the bario
which features the warhammer titan and
multiple titan shifters belonging to the
marland warriors clashing against
aaron's attack titan and the scouts from
parodies
the warhammer titan user is forced out
of her crystal
after aaron uses the jaw titan's jaw as
basically a giant
nutcracker aaron is able to crack the
crystal and force the warhammer titans
user out
and he is then able to consume willie
tiber's sister
which grants him possession of yet
another titan power
as of the making of this video aaron
possesses three titan powers
the founding titan the attack titan and
the warhammer titan
after gaining this new titan power we
see aaron using the warhammer titan
ability
in several ways he uses its unique
hardening ability to
dig out of prison and he then reseals
the hole
so that no one can follow him he also
uses it in battle to make
giant spikes grow out of his titan's
back and
out of the ground which of course makes
it much harder for other titans to
attack him or sneak up on him
including the most agile titans such as
the jaw titan
later when emir fritz revives titan
shifters from the past
in order to protect aaron's new titan
form from the anti-aaron alliance
we actually get to see some earlier
versions of the warhammer titan shifter
including one that looks like he is
wearing a medieval knight's
helmet and that is what we know so far
about the warhammer titan and the
mysterious tiber family
this titan has multiple abilities that
are distinctly its own
and its versatile hardening power makes
it an incredibly useful titan shifter
especially in battle its ability to be
remotely controlled while the user is
safely sealed away
inside a crystal is also a major
advantage
and if it wasn't for aaron's play of the
game decision to use porco's jaw titan
as a nutcracker
willie tiber's sister would probably
still be the warhammer titans holder
luckily for aaron the warhammer titan's
abilities were able to combine
very nicely with the abilities of his
attack
titan and as a result aaron was able to
become extremely powerful
in his titan form after he managed to
gain the warhammer
titan and now let me know what you guys
think do you like
the warhammer titan and are you a fan of
its unique
powers and abilities where does this
titan shifter rank
in terms of your favorite titan shifter
powers
and in what other ways do you expect
that aaron is going to use this power
before the story
ends don't forget to leave your feedback
down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more attack on time videos right
here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime opera
or maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including ingrata the
world acquired respect liam thompson
pate hepha rathee and yx
phoenix anime emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life tonell
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokamian water the red-haired raven
florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games
manwa freaks deadly saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar gives you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you